ton souvent varié pécresse que pour être
président de la république pour être élu
président de la république il faut être
un peu dingue vous paraissez très normal
est-ce que vous avez un côté dengue qui
nous aurait échappé évidemment j'ai un
côté dingue je me suis levé et je me
suis dit je vais devenir président de la
république française d'hier s'est déjà
dingue pourquoi je les fais j'ai fait
parce que j'ai l'impression que mon pays
est abîmée j'ai l'impression est est ce
que je viens d'entendre me le prouve
encore plus j'ai l'impression que mon
pays ne va pas bien j'ai l'impression
que l'école ne marche plus j'ai
l'impression que la santé est en grande
souffrance j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
plus dort dans la rue j'ai l'impression
que voilà que que on a besoin de moi
c'est pour ça que je me suis levée et
c'est pour ça que je me suis je me suis
mobilisé pour être là vous pas la tête
du pays vous possédez une petite
polémique au début de l'année enfin ou
juste avant le réveillon vous savez le
président de la république avait mis
sous l'arc de triomphe uniquement le
drapeau européen puisqu'il prenait la
présidence de l'union européenne et ça
ça donnait le sentiment qu'il voulait
une europe fédérale le front national
monsieur zemmour on dit ah là là nous on
veut pas voir ce drapeau européen on
veut voir que le drapeau français sous
l'arc de triomphe moi j'ai dit faisons
comme nous l'avions fait au moment de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne sous sarkozy embrassons les
deux drapeaux moi je suis patriote et je
suis européenne je pense qu'il faut une
france forte dans une roue union
européenne puissante mais je le dis si
je suis président de la république je
défendrai les intérêts de la france dans
l'europe pourquoi je dis ça et parce
qu'on voit bien qu emmanuel macron à
laisser bafouer ses intérêts de la
france dans l'europe prenons le
nucléaire par exemple vous savez que
l'allemagne a réussi à faire inscrire
les centrales au gaz dans le plan de
relance énergétique de l'europe alors
que nous n'avions pas réussi à faire
inscrire les centrales nucléaires c'est
inacceptable seront elles seront peut
être enregistré comme ça comme énergie
de transit de transition mais ce n'est
pas une énergie de transition on veut
arriver à zéro carbone en 2050 on a un
agenda qui sont les accords de paris on
ne respecte aucun aucun des engagements
qui a été pris qui ont été pris lors des
accords de paris emmanuel macron ne les
a pas respectés nous ne sommes pas sur
la trt victoire voulu pour avoir
seulement un degré et demi de plus donc
ça n'est pas possible on est aujourd'hui
mauvais élève par rapport aux échos aux
accords de paris il faut aujourd'hui que
georges tout cela ont rédigé une loi
constitutionnelle est les écrits de
cette loi tout le monde peut la
consulter sur internet et dans cette loi
on fixe une nouvelle règle du jeu c'est
des quotas migratoires voté par le
parlement chaque année et le principe
c'est simple on accueille qui ont choisi
d'accueillir et avec un principe simple
si vous voulez des visas il faut
reprendre vos clandestins vous voulez
pas vous reprenez pas vos clandestins
vous n'avez plus de visas 0 visa mais la
panse que on ne peut pas aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui se faire marcher
sur les pieds un grand pays il établit
ses règles et c'est ce que je dis là
c'est ce que font les états unis c'est
ce que fait le canada c'est ce que va
faire la grande bretagne maintenant
qu'elle est plus dans l'union européenne
c'est ce que fait l'australie c'est pas
des pays qui sont des dictatures c'est
pas des scellés pays qui font juste
respecter leurs frontières et leurs
règles du jeu donc moi c'est un donnant
donnant le sujet c'est que c'est qu'ils
aiment la france et que idées soient
fiers d'être français alors dans ce
contexte pardon et l'école doux
d'où vraiment on travaille sur
l'histoire de france m'ont trahi sur la
politique culturelle moi je veux que
l'éducation artistique et culturelle
soit partout dans les écoles un peu dès
la maternelle on apprenne la culture
française je sais que la culture c'est
notre ciment donc voilà alors vas y
avait offert un peuple une nation et ce
sera le grand défi du prochain mandat
fair nation est ce que nous avons tous
envie ici d'avoir un destin commun
est-ce qu'on a tous envie encore d'être
un grand peuple voilà alors la relève le
réseau d'accès soient nos origines quand
on est au bord du gouffre évidemment
prendre des décisions en urgence parce
qu'il ya une élection dans trois mois
mais aujourd'hui la politique energia ce
qui a aussi déjà poli d'altenach geiger
du président de la république est une
politique énergétique qui aujourd'hui
conduit edf à au naufrage et si nous
avons une entreprise publique qui n'a
pas les moyens d'investir dans ces dans
ces grandes centrales demain nous
risquons des coupures d'énergie et nous
n'atteindrons pas le zéro carbone en
2050 et aujourd'hui moi je veux une
relance gaullienne du nucléaire je vais
une politique énergétique
d'investissement et c'est pas avec
l'échec toutes les semaines des nagel
macron le chef des relations pareil vous
n'auriez pas fait mais vous vous rendez
compte que aujourd'hui on vit avec des
chèques payés avec nos impôts donc c'est
une politique de gribouille sous
politique de clientélisme électoral pour
les élections voilà là vaut mieux donner
du salaire aux français et ça c'est mon
projet j'y suis allé en france et vivre
dignement de leur salaire plutôt que de
vivre de chèques qui sont faits par
l'état à trois mois des élections
personne n'est dupe jusqu'avant
justement des raisons pour lesquelles
certains de vote plus fait des économies
plus que personne n'en fait je suis
désolé j'ai le président de la
république qui a fait une émission télé
pour dire que c'était mal de penser
réduire de 200 milles l'administration
administrante et de supprimer des postes
de fonctionnaires en ne remplaçant pas
les départs à la retraite donc le
président de la république lui même a
dit à la télévision que faire des
économies s'étaient pas bien parce que
j'en faisais oui je vais faire des
économies et ses économies me
permettront parce que je suis désolé
mais 72 -
32 c'était quand même 40 milliards oui
sauf g je réduis les difficiles dans mon
programme que soient documentés dans mon
programme jeux réduits de 40 milliards
les déficits